>>> A NEW BOOK IS NGISTADURINGD
COMMIT YRSHE
IMPORTANCE OT AL BELIEVE --
AND IT'SIT TO ARK
UNITED STATES NATORS WHO BUILT
THEIR REPUTATIONS AND CAREERN
THE SEGREGATION OF RAC
COUNTRY.
DO YOUGR TODAYHAT YOU WERE
WRONG PPICA?
>> DO YOU RE
>> I D NOT OPPOSING IN
AMERICA.
WHAT I OPPOSED IS BUSSIND BY TH
AMERICA.S PART OF THE SECOND CL
TO INTEGRATE BERKELEY,
CALIFORNIA, PUBLICCHN
V. BOARD OF EDUCATION.
LEANING OVER TO PETE BUTTIGIEGA.
HE WAS LOOKINGO HIM.
OOKING TO SHARE WITH HE SAID,L,
EFFINGUP THERE CALM A
RAST WITHOUT B
GO EFF YOURSELF.
JOINING U NO A STAFF WRITER
FOR "THE TOO
IT'S N ALED "BE SOUL: GNS TOEAA.
NOT SURPRING HERE,SA
JILL BIDEN TOOK THIS PERSONALLY.
HANKS R HA
BIGGEST MOMENT OF THE PRIMAR
CAMPAIGN.
IT WAS SOMETLL BIDEN
AND JOE BIDEN TOOKY
PELYRY ANGRY ABOUT IT.
THAT CES ACROSS IN
LANGUAGE REPORTED
THAT WAS THROUT ED A LONG TIME.
IT LASTED THROUG THEY WERE
DECIDING WHAT THES LOO
IT LEFT RK.
THEY HAVE GOTTEN OVER IT SCEEN.
THEY'RE SERVINER
WORKING WELLBU T
IT WAS IRERE
>>ON OF
HE IT.
YOU KNOW, YES, WHAT YOU JUST PO.
BUE SOMEE MOST NG STUFF WAS
WHAT IT RED BEFORE ABOUT
PRESIDENT AM LOTS OF STUFF
AND HOW HERI TPROJECT COOL
I TO TRUMP'S ELECTION
AND DISBELIEF.
HEOTF PEOPLE
CURSING IN THEYS.  G ATE MES
INCLUDING FROM PRESIDENT OBAMA
MS SEE IN THE WAY HE REACTED TO
THINKING, OKAY, MAYBE L
E WON'T CHT TO TO VERYUICKLY AN
ESONE OF CLOSEST
ADVISERS WHO SAYS
ELEC MADE OBAMA FEE
THERE WAS MORE RACISM IN THE
ITRUMP  THAN HREALIZED AND HE DI
N DURING THE
TRANSI H GOTTEN MUCH
DARKER ABOUT IT AND WA
LONGER AE  IGNORE IT IN THAT
SAME
>> IT'S LIKE A MOMENT OF
SIT OF WHAT MAKES IT SO
INTERESTING IN THE WAKE OF
TRUMP'S ELECTION.
ONE OF THE THINGS YOU REIS BOO .
>> LOOK.
DEMOCRATS  FRY EARLY  THINKING N
IN 2020?
WHO'S GOING TO RUN
THERS  WHERE OBAMA
IT'S DECEMBEOF 2017.ATE AN
AND THEY'RE SO
GAME LIKE A LOT EO YOU THINKT C
BE.O DO YOUT
IN YOUR HEAD, WHO DO
YOU EART, AND
WHO DO YOU THINK CAN.
IN HIS HEAD IT W COMMANDER EN W
BIDEN.OICES HEART WAS
WIN, OBVIOUSLY HIM,  LF PEOPLEKT
HE HRE
BACK FROM SOMETH
BUT BI
HEART AND SOMEBODY THAT HELOVED
THROUGHOUT HOW BIDEN WOULD DO AS
A CANDIDATE.
>>OOI WAS GENUINEL
YOURTING.EA CAN
READ THESE BOOKSSURPRIBYHINGS YN
PRESIDENCYA REACHE GEORGE W.  P
ATIN OF THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION OR AT R T
ENT ON HERE?
MOMENT.HAVE TO REMEMBER THE
IT R DEMOCRATS
DO REALLY WELL IN THE MIDTERMS E
THERE'S A PANIC, HOW FAR
GOING TO GO, IS THIS GOING T
ANOTR "SATURDAY NIGHT AND ALREA
HAVE BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT THE
GHT TAKE, AND THEY
THOUGHT, DO WE HAV P
AND AN IDEA STTO BE TALKED
TOGETHER WITH GEORH AND SERS TOT
SA HERE'S A REPUBLICAN
PRESIDA DEMOCRATIC
THIS G F D
OBAMEXERM.
HE WAS HIREDNDUSH.
IT NEVER GOT TO THE LEVEL OF
S BUSH FOR IT, B WAS SOME TESTI
WITH BUSH FOLKS TO SEEF  INTERE.
THER.
DOESN'T WANT T INVOLVED IN
CS OR ANYTHING ELSE, AND
THAT WAS THE SENSE HGAVE HIM
THEN.
>> YOURTAND, OF
COURSE, LOOK.
A LOT OF DEMOCRATS ATTRIBUTE
BIDEN'S PRIMAR SOUTH
CAROLINA BY THE FACTS
ENRSY CONGRESSMAN JIM
CL
SUEYORME
YOWRHE NEARLDN'T GET
THE FOURTH ANDESAC
THE PACK ANDGOT TO J
CLYBUR
CLYB HT GOING TO TRY
HE ULTIMATELY COME THINKDY E
TO THIS DECISION?EMEMBER, JOE B
CAN FORGET HOW BAD THINGS WERE
IN 2020.IT WASOU IN
THE IOWA CAUCUS.IN NEWPSHIRE.
HEASN'T THERE ON THE
CTUALLY BEINTED.
HE'S LIKED BIDEN, ALWAYSED RSON
E RESULTS AND ID EVEN TH I
ENDORSE HIM, MY
M S NOT
D, FARACK FROM  A HE  CAU
STRONG ENOUGH FINISH TO CONVINCE
CLURRE
THERE WAS SOME THERE?HE CAME  BN
LOOKING AT BIDEN.
>> LIKE WHO?
>> IT'S IN THE BOOK.
D THOK THERE WAS ONE PR
IN THERE,
BUT WHATH CLYBUR
ELIBERATE MOVE
IMPORTANT AND TO HA ROLE
HERE, INITELY
YOU SEE ALE WATO B
O CLYBURN, THAWAS THE E WHO MAD
DICE IN GETTINBIDEN
>> AND, AGAIN, THE
IF PEOPLE READ THIS BO
T  WERE MP TALKED, YOU KW --
ABOUT KALA
WHO S DEN'S SECOND CHOICE
HERE?
STRUCK BY THIS.ALA LITTLE
BI A RRE IN HELPING TO
TIP THSCKAMALA
>>
TOO BACK TO KAMALA HS,OF THE BI
THINKING ABOUT VER
PICKING HIS RUNNING MATE WAS WA.
EY GREW VERY CLOSE.
R LIREW OVER
R THOSE YEARS. WERE IN THE
HETO RE-CREATE THAT.
THE REASON THE DEBATE MOMENT
MATTERED IS BECAUSDE HE
OD ON F AND
WAND IN Y  THAT ND
CLHAT HE
WANTEDSOF THE
CONVERSATION STRAIS
BAMA WHOAS AN
ADVISER TO HIM TE
E N RUNNING OUGH
MATE PROCESSOBAMA SAID TO
OINT, YOU TO
MEART OUT
ALL THAT CLOSE.
IF YOU GO  TO 2009 AT THISINT I
HOUSE THIRD QUARTER WERE NOT
GETTING ALONG THATEL
BUT IT TIM A
BROTHERLY RELATIONSHIPHAT A PIE
ASY DRAWN  GRETCHEN D RSONALLY
NED UP IN A
OF WAYS.
HE HAD -- IT LEA T SHE FLEW
OUT SECRO MEET WH HI